thanks to a patreon Commission I have
done something that I haven't done in
about three years finish the book yes
folks this is gonna be the first sort of
for formal book review that I think I've
ever done on this channel
um I'd mentioned books from time to time
usually in relation to how movies
screwed them up
um and things like that but um I haven't
actually read one in quite a while but I
got commissioned through patreon to take
a look at a Terry Pratchett book I was
actually it was funny um god how much
background I want to give on this I was
basically given a list of Terry
Pratchett books I picked a title at
random um I could without doing more
research looking into them just based
off the fact that the person who
commissioned me was like this one's
probably good if you don't have a lot of
background too Terry project which I
don't and that ended up being the
monstrous regimen
this is a Discworld book I think it's
like Discworld it's like book 31 or
something I've never read Discworld
before I have actually read Terry
Pratchett but the only Terry Pratchett
thing I've read is good omens which you
wrote with Neil Gaiman so I've never
dealt with full-on Pratchett before this
is new for me um I did know a little bit
about Discworld only insofar as it was
kind of a somewhat satirical comedy
leaning fantasy series of books that was
about all I really knew well that and
it's spun off into like a PC adventure
and was some of the most legendary moon
logic puzzles ever devised but in any
case when I first got this thing this
thing yeah this is darn near 500 pages
and when I got it and I flipped through
it I thought oh well let me just see how
long any given chapters so I know how to
parse this out
guess what this doesn't have and I guess
most terry pratchet books don't have
chapters and it's not to say there's no
segmentation at all but there's no chat
it's not broken into chapters in any way
whatsoever so here's the really amazing
thing about this book though because to
jump to the end a little bit
I liked this quite a bit for as thick as
this is it actually if you were to to
sketch out everything that happens
chronologically it's not actually all
that much this it's not long because of
huge epic scope it's long because of the
way
Pratchett writes and the amount of
detail and the flourish that he gives to
his stories he reminds me a bit of
Douglas Adams and I want to but in a
very specific way is not it's not quite
the same style of humor and obviously
atoms usually messed about with sci-fi
but what I mean is what makes the this
story good is less the nuts and bolts of
the actual plot but just the use of
language in describing it though the
turns of phrase that he will come up
with in order to describe something
though or the way something felt for the
characters that is the kind of stuff
that make that it kind of ends up
patting out what would otherwise be a
fairly straightforward story but it's
because he has a flourish and a flair
and describing things but it not like
purple prose but just like dry-weight in
in the way that things get described and
it just it just makes it really really
fun alright plot for this I'm I don't
think I'll end up getting to spoilers
but if any we're gonna go there I'll let
you know so this is set in Discworld in
a small country called Boer gravia which
is at war and has been for a very very
long time
the main character is Polly who is a
young woman
who cuts her hair short stuffs some
socks down her trousers and pretends to
be a man to join the army in order to
find her brother who she believes to be
captured by the enemy that's your
starting premise so right off the bat
your initial start is like oh okay so
this is gonna be a fairly typical boy
becomes a man's story through war
that's pretty tried and true a ground to
go with but the twist is it's a girl
pretending to be a boy okay cool and
that's where it starts but what I really
enjoy about this is that the story kept
going in directions I expected but then
doing things like once it goes starts
going down that path it would do things
differently from how I expected them and
that's kind of a hard way to describe
but I'll talk about some of the
characters as a way just to describe
that so two of the the major supporting
characters are the the sergeant and the
lieutenant that Polly is answering to
the sergeant is sergeant Jack Rowe who
is a very rut you know rough-and-tumble
on the ground I'll take care of my boys
you know kind of sergeant it's it's a
bit of a military trope and the
lieutenant is a bit of a oh well you
know I I just I've read books and I
understand numbers and I I'm sure we'll
give them a jolly good wallop you know
kind of thing you know he's foppish he's
he's not battle-hardened he has no
experience again fairly tried-and-true
trope now normally in this situation
what you would expect is for the
lieutenant to be completely useless and
nothing but a detriment and the end the
sergeant to be the one who who knows
what's actually going on in and you know
it has all the right answers and that
happens to an extent but it also gets
undercut because as it goes along you
realize sometimes Jack rums way of going
about the
no that's actually not a great idea and
in fact the lieutenant has a better idea
but also not always so like what you
realize about say lieutenant blouse is
that yeah his name is blouse is that he
doesn't have he definitely has none of
Jack Rome's experience but he's still
looking at things with more intelligence
and more analytical nature than people
on the battlefield tend to and he's he
is coming up intermittently with things
that nobody else on the squad considers
and is actually a good idea and works
really well and there are times that he
stands his ground and pulls his rank
he's like oh crap he's actually right
but then that's not a moment we're like
oh and he'll always be right from here
oh no cuz he's still that far but he's
still then he does this and Jack crumbs
gotta come in but then Jack room like
goes too far and we got so like the
power dynamic between the two of them
kept shifting around in ways that were
not what I expected given especially
even the fact that the template that
these characters fit was pretty standard
for a you know young man becomes a boy
becomes a man in on the field of battle
kind of story so like I said like on
paper so much of this is fairly standard
stuff but just with the right amount of
little twist here and there and also I
got to learn a little bit about the
world of Discworld and I really like
that the weirdness and oddities of this
fantasy world are just integrated into
the story for the most part as if this
is this was stuff you already knew like
it'll explain a little bit like like
when there's a troll that that like
throws a rock at another troll and
everyone's like oh god is this affine
they're like no that's like basically
saying hello so like stuff like that
gets explained but it's not like and
here's where the trolls came from in the
history of the chudd I know there's just
trolls here it's just a troll move on so
so on that basis the
other members some of the other members
of the monstrous regiment we have a
number of other just young men and you
know very cons is one who's like very
into the the very crazy religion that
the burg Ravens have a you know and
there's one it's just very quiet this
one is very mmm but then you've also got
a coffee addicted vampire you've got a
troll and you've got an Igor and it's
hard like it's very intuitive what the
igor's are but to try and explain it
feels very weird it basically it's like
an entire clan of mad scientists
assistants and they have they understand
bodies very well and they're great on
the field medics and if they lose a
patient they'll they'll preserve
whatever body parts they think they can
use to help somebody else later but
coming back to the religion thing there
there's a lot of satire going on in this
book there's satire of the military
there is satire of gender dynamics there
is satire of religion but what I really
appreciate about it is that partly
because the the world of Discworld does
not feel analogous to anything nothing
feels like it's meant to be a one-to-one
comparative to the real world like is
not skewering something super specific
these are broad ideas so that helps but
then even beyond that the satire is
surprisingly gentle so like there is
satire of sort of the overly masculine
military mindset while at the same time
still finding some value in that there
is a skewing of the the followers of
noggin who is the insane god that the
Borg Ravens worship who keeps declaring
you know all these abominations like he
declared beats an abomination which is
the staple crop so now they just have to
figure out how to live without beats you
know that's the
kind of stuff that that that they have
to deal with which is obviously insane
but they just kind of do it and yet at
the same time there is a certain amount
of validation of
for some characters of faith so it it's
not a blanket religion is dumb it is a
this specific religion going on over
here is hurting the people and that's
bad and again because it doesn't feel
analogous to a specific real world
religion it doesn't come across as
mean-spirited or even necessarily
skewering the idea of faith it's poking
at the idea of we do this just because
we we don't stop and go wait a minute
what and it's skewing that idea and
filtering it through faith but it
doesn't feel like a ha ha ha religion is
dumb thing because it trust me if it
felt like that that would have annoyed
me but it didn't and the same with the
gender politics and the same with the
military politics and with some of the
stuff of the heavens towards the end and
I have now decided I'm not gonna spoil
it but with some of the things you
realize towards the end with what's
going on it really felt like it was
pushing it and like if I were gonna
nitpick just slightly some of these sort
of climactic stuff there's there's
extended series of characters kind of
just having speeches for lack of a
better term I think that goes on a
little too long both for individual
speeches and that section but it still
pays off really well and it feels earned
and like there's God there's honestly
this video could end up going on forever
there are so many great characters in
this the entire squad is terrific
the officers are great there are one-off
small characters that are excellent
there it's but again like despite being
this thick and super you and you having
a lot of characters and and a lot and a
lot going on in the world the narrative
is pretty straightforward join the army
fight the enemy here's the specific goal
that they have right now let's see that
if they can do that and that's basically
it so there is a lot going on but built
around a very sound
simple structure and through all that
it's just a really good book I've had
people telling me I should read Terry
Pratchett for years and I wish I could
say that this means I'll start reading a
bunch Terry Pratchett but like this took
me a while I wanted to have I was
commissioned for this review a couple
months ago and I don't like to take that
long to get to commissioned reviews but
it's hard for me to find the time to
read but I'm really glad I did this was
good and this was fun and this was funny
and and and I can vouch for the fact
that as someone who's never read the
Discworld book before my life still good
you don't need to have read the other
stuff if you know fantasy tropes at all
even a little bit you can roll with this
it's real easy so that's the monstrous
regiment first time I read Terry
Pratchett I got a I got a mm I need to
invent more hours so that I can read
more of his stuff because otherwise I
don't know if I'll ever get to do it but
I'm definitely glad I read this the
monstrous regimen have you read it what
did you think about it do you read
Discworld in general what's your
favorite Discworld book whatever your
thoughts on any of this are drop them
down in the comments let's talk about it
all stuff to do it's linked down their
social media patreon you know the drill
click on it or you also don't have to
it's okay because at the end of the day
folks you're the council I'm just
running meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]